Linda is in Minnesota hi Linda welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show your question
for dr. John Bologna Oh to speak with
you I look I have a question so for dr.
B mine so my husband now works from home
and I have a 13 year old and a 16 year
old who are home and we just found out
today that they're not going back to
school this school year so we have just
four people in our house which is
getting smaller by the minute
and stress and I'm nervous and scared
and my husband's got a temper and my
daughter's sad and my Hut my son is 13
and squirrely and we're all going crazy
and I just wanted to know if there's
something you can tell me that I could
call my solder home especially my
daughter she's just fat hmm so a couple
of important things how old's your
daughter McGrady chien
oh you told me that 16 years old right
yep she's in parents house so a couple
of important things here number one as a
family and the best you can to get your
husband around the table on this sit
together do it tonight and grieve the
loss and actually verbalize this stinks
that you lost your school year and talk
about the things that you're gonna miss
talk about the things that aren't gonna
happen you're not gonna have in a school
party event a school dances whatever
those things are gonna be and
acknowledge the milestones if you don't
acknowledge them they just take wings
and roots and they grow inside your head
and your soul and then it just compounds
and turns into this messy spinny junky
mess and so acknowledge them think of it
this way don't call up this in public
but think of holding a mini funeral for
the things that we lost grieve them and
actually name them and then they kind of
lose their power a little bit and then
the second most important thing that I
think is gonna make the rest of this the
rest of this uncertain time until your
husband goes back to work or till you
kind of get in the rhythm of what a
summer is going to look like is to start
every single day with a plan get all
four people around a table I use this
she's a little note card and every
morning I asked my wife what's the
picture of today look like and we get
the kids and we do a family hug and then
we all take off but it's that short time
it could be 10 minutes 15 minutes it
just says here's what today looks like
it's everybody on the same plan here's
the deal our brains take familiar for
safe that's why people stay in crummy
marriages way too long that's what they
work for junky bosses for way too long
because it just feels safe
neurologically and so nothing feels
familiar for your family right now and
so this practice of making a plan every
day it sounds so lame and so cheesy just
trust me on it
make a plan every morning make sure
everybody's on the same page and over
the next couple of days just the act of
making a plan becomes familiar everybody
exhales a little bit and then you get on
about your day people are gonna bump
into each other you're gonna have to be
graceful and your kids are gonna be
annoying because that's just what kids
do it's actually 13 to 16 year old god
bless you and you're gonna have to be
direct with your husband and you about
making sure you all choose to take time
to connect with one another but you can
do that start with making a plan every
morning yeah John is there any is it
wise or not I'm not leading you because
I truly don't know the answer the
question to call some of this out and
say okay thirteen-year being a squirrel
I'm mom I'm being afraid 16 year old
direct and depressed dad your tempers
driving the rest of us nuts
do you call some of that out if if dad's
got the if dad's got is it will act like
a grown-up yes if he doesn't get mad
when you do it that's right so if you
what will happen it at the planning
meeting is if they do it right in about
day three or four they'll get real
annoying and then it will be an organic
conversation because you've got to
practice talking first if you practice
with pointing out hey you were acting
like this and it becomes an attack than
my wall school okay so if you practice
making a plan then by Friday
like Susan you've got to stop being
annoying and Billy you're just leaving
your junk everywhere and we get it we're
sad we got to move on and husband you
can't be like that like I need you to go
for a walk right but it starts with this
practice it's just a it's just a daily
practice of making a plan together and
then yes then you get comfortable enough
calling each other out
in a respectful dignified way because
you're now doing it within a framework
that's right okay we're okay I mean
otherwise it's just accusations yeah I
just becomes when you come to me about
name-calling that's right all right I
got you okay interesting and dad's
across the country and I'm looking in
the mirror when I say this be nice to
your families when you're working from
home I know it's frustrating I know it's
hard
honor your family's honor your families
this is hard hard season yeah it's um
well I mean we process fear anxiety we
can't control things we were controlling
we thought we were and sometimes we
process that as anger that's exactly
right or sometimes we process it with
withdrawal so in my house I don't get
allowed I withdraw that's my I go hide
and when I start hiding then I start
getting lonely when I get lonely my
little anxiety alarms go off and then I
end off down the road somewhere usually
covered up in gummy candy and peeps and
all kinds of other always goes back to
junk food I tell you what man but yeah
this idea of when I feel myself starting
to lean this way then I now know I've
got to lean back this way I've got to
take my son's hand and say let's go for
a walk or I gotta pick my daughter up
let's go run around the backyard and
I've got to go hug my wife intentionally
so I have to be a grown-up about that
and some some folks their default
setting is they get angry they get loud
they get frustrated and they've got to
be able to say the words I'm sorry they
hit words I was wrong they gotta be able
to say I gotta go for a walk right it's
about knowing yourself
blow off steam with the wall yeah
or shove it down with gummy candy one
it's one of the team one more time we
get in one more plug for the peeps